all right my story is a French inventor  his name is Frankie Zapata has made  history by being the first to fly across  the English Channel look at this on a  hoverboard love it okay he he flew 22  miles in about 22 minutes his top speed  was about a hundred and six miles an  hour he actually tried this last month  but failed because the he had to  actually refuel in the middle of it by  switching to another backpack didn't  work and he ended up in the ocean the  first time this time he made it you may  have noticed he also appeared at  Bastille Day last month in France in a  big military parade that's the first  time I noticed with him but I become  kind of fascinated by it incredible it's  my flying car from the Jetsons oh there  you go  I love this there we go they the future  is right there I'll get around like that  think what for what the world work could  be a mess the world bit yeah it would  it's interesting we might want to  regulate it a little bit up in the air  there